[Music]
listen up folks
nicole putarowski wants you to know she
doesn't hate angelina jolie
the ex of her rumored beau brad pitt
it's a very nice feeling
here's what went down on tuesday the 27
year old german model posted
these snaps rocking an orange top with
shades
she captioned the pics quote happy
people don't hate
well that prompted one commenter to
chime in
writing if so then why you and brad hate
angelina
practice what you preach girl her
response
not hating anyone well that kicked off a
debate in the comments with
some fans coming to her defense and
others straight up throwing shades
one supporter wrote quote come on nicole
never said she hates angie
it was always the pabst creating stories
and saying a source close to reported
i think it's only brad who is dealing
with angie nicole has no business there
nicole replied to that comment writing
simply
amen rumors that brad and nicole are a
thing
sparked back in august when they were
spotted in france
it's really exciting at the time a
source told et that their lovers getaway
was
even news to some of their nearest and
dearest
adding that the two were introduced
through friends and when they first
started seeing each other
they didn't tell anyone quote even some
of their inner circle of friends
are only finding out now oh i don't know
you know i mean the source adds that
brad who split from angelina in 2016
has been very private about dating quote
now more than ever he doesn't want to
rock the boat with angelina
he has been working so hard on making
his co-parenting
run smoothly you know we want to make it
a family fair as for nicole
according to e.t source she has a lot in
common with the 56 year old actor
and they get along really well quote her
friends describe her as super easy going
she is very down to earth and far from
starstruck which has been really nice
for brad
i'm pretty grateful for that